In Afghanistan, a suicide bomber on a motorbike...
...attacked a joint US-Afghan patrol near Bagram Airfield,...
...killing six NATO soldiers and wounding three others.
In China, authorities say 91 people are missing...
...after a massive landslide buried an industrial park in the southern city of Shenzhen.
In Belgium, police have detained five people, including two brothers,...
...during a series of raids connected to last month's Paris attacks.
In Spain, Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy says he has received a democratic mandate...
...to try and form a government after Sunday's general election.
And finally from Libya,...
...two migrants drowned while more than a hundred are rescued in the Mediterranean,...
...after a boat en route to Italy got into trouble.